hi um today i'd like to just over it's a
brief introduction short film
about um
what i'm saying
by masters
the top sheet hands seventh dance
on youtube i seem to have a lot of time
on my hands i don't know why whether
it's the
covered pandemic giving us more time
or being retired but anyhow so i'd like
to ask you all a question and something
to think about
this is uh
really a
a starting film
about
locking of the body
you see aikido we all know
is about
locking of the joints
and throws
but
that's not just the immobilizations that
uh ikkyo nikkiyosenko yonkiyo gokyo yeah
these are locks normally on the elbows
and the arms shoulders
but there's also
something that people don't often think
about locking the actual body the whole
frame
you know so that we we just can't move
in the whole
frame
and um
there's a misbelief that
when you hear the teachers demonstrate
and show tension aggie for for
this instance
tension aggie
is a locking of heaven and earth
in my opinion anyhow and
there's only the two that i know at plus
kilometers
and the two-handed one
where
you can keep in the garden you would you
would take them as they come in
up
to lock them and then
step through
throwing them down
this
lower hand is the important one
because it tucks behind their buttock
and they the only uk from it is a judo
slap
for them for okay on the floor there was
no backwood chemi no fall who came out
of a true tension aggie
and i'm saying a lot on youtube by the
teacher saying announcing its tension
aggie where in fact it's actually a
coconutty
we can call it a breath throw
but
you know they're throwing the person
away from them
like this and that allows them to throw
there's no locking of the body where
true
ki hong tinchinagi is a locking of the
body
so whether you're
taking them as they come in the
kindergarten
that's an adaptation of the basic the
basic is the two wrist
grab
you lock
the bottom hand
either behind their
butter in my case i'm going to the left
so it would be locked behind the white
butter
behind the cheek of the
light butter
and you lock that arm up which has
anybody who has my book either my ebook
that's now available on amazon
or my hard copy
i think it's page 114 or 141 so
please have a look at that
and it will show you the
how their
their arm is locked in a straight
straight up
there is also a one-handed one where
they grab category
and you do exactly the same but you lock
their arm
and shoulder with their body
the top hand is the other side of their
neck but it's the lock
the lock
okay so we we actually lock their body
there's nowhere they can move they can't
move forward or back
and it's into
the ground
flatten that back
using a judo slap
if you want to know the full in-depth
detail by detail precise
knowledge of this you'll have to
subscribe to my patreon page so you can
find the details below
thanks for watching and
[Music]
i hope you
this will prick your mind to want to
know more
but um
most of what you'll see is kokunagi
okay not
tension
tensioning is a
heaven and earth
locking together and the human in the
middle is locked in that
understanding
thank you for your time
and i hope that you become a member of
my patreon and
we'll all
get finer points
improving our aikido
in the future
thank you